[Music]
the US government is quietly reshaping
the global economy in ways that will
change our world
forever you can see this in just one
sentence from Joe Biden's first address
to
Congress think about it there is simply
no reason why the blades for wind
turbines can't be built in Pittsburgh
instead of Beijing no
reason no
reason none this seems just like aor
political statement but I promise this
statement is a bigger deal than it seems
because it marks a new era in our global
system A system that all of us
participate in whether we know it or not
or maybe it's a rerun of an economic
system that the globe turned to right
before the second world war there's no
reason why
American American workers can't lead the
world in the production of electric
vehicles and batteries I mean there is
no reason you have the
[Applause]
capacity in in this video I want to peek
under the hood of the endlessly complex
and fascinating global economy to show
you just how deeply connected we've all
become and how those connections are
being cut and weaponized all of this
thanks to new threats new risks new
realizations new values and above all a
new rivalry between two great Powers
this is the world that we are moving
into it's how things will work for
decades to come and it's important that
we understand
it so let me give you an overview of
what is becoming the new global economy
the new tariffs from both sides went
into effect earlier this morning the US
tariffs have kicked in China can't put
as many tariffs on us as we can put on
them China is still the biggest threat
to the United
States folks we need to make these chips
right here in
America hey so for a long time I've been
at war with marketers people who call my
phone even though I don't want them to
and who send me emails even though I
never gave them my email address we're
all from amiliar with this it's called
spam and it is increasingly a problem
but then I recently learned that I
actually have the right to request that
I be taken off of all of the lists that
people use to buy and sell my
information the problem is even though I
have all these rights I'm not going to
go through the process of like
requesting a formal like removal of my
name off of every one of these hundreds
of data broker lists that I'm on incog
is the sponsor of today's video which is
why I'm talking about this I'm very
grateful to them for supporting our
journalism I signed up for incog and I
gave them permission to act on my behalf
to go take my name off of data broker
lists and then they start the process of
requesting that your name be taken off
some of these companies are kind of
shady and they like try to push back and
incog takes the time to follow up and
push until you are taken off that list
the best part is you get to watch the
progress all on this nice dashboard that
tells you what lists your name has been
taken off of I recently learned just how
pervasive these data broker lists are
like they use it not only to like fill
up your inbox with Spam but also to like
track your web browsing activity which
they then can sell to like a health
insurance company which could like Jack
up your premiums luckily in cogy has
helped strip me away from these lists
and my phone is now strangely quiet my
inbox is not a hornet's nest so if you
want to try this out there's a link in
my description it is
constantly monitors month after month to
make sure that you stay off these lists
so yeah big discount click the link in
my description use the code and you'll
get the big discount you can try it out
and see if it clears your life of spam
and makes you feel like you have a
little more privacy in your life let's
dive into this story it's a big one it's
an important one and I'm excited to
share it with
you the economy that we live in that we
all take for granted is actually
relatively new the clothes that you're
wearing right now the computer or the
phone that you're looking at to watch
this video the material materials that
your house is made out of the fibers in
the blanket that you use at night the
food you eat all of it is a product of
perhaps one of the most significant
achievements of our species global
trade early on humans discovered the
magic that occurs when a group of people
specialize in producing something
valuable like grain they make more than
they need and then they take that excess
and they give it to another group who
also made too much of something because
they specialize in a specific thing
maybe textiles and through this exchange
both parties benefit way more than they
could on their own it was this kind of
cooperation that leveled our species up
Beyond any other animal on earth so we
just kept doing it in fact the history
of our human civilization is largely the
history of people trading on an Ever
growing scale today this is normal we
call it the economy by the time the
1900s rolled around we had a pretty
connected World there was global trade
all over the place but it was still
pretty clunky everyone had different
Trad trade rules different currencies
countries were worried that foreign
products would threaten their domestic
producers so they put up trade barriers
and imposed big tariffs on stuff coming
into their country then 70 years ago
came that war that almost tore this
world
apart out of the ashes of that war the
US emerged as the most powerful country
ever it had troops and influence in
every corner of the globe and with that
new power the US and its allies wrote a
new playbook for the world economy they
would make it so that the US dollar was
the top currency everything would kind
of be pegged to the US dollar this
helped stabilize the whole system it
helped it move more predictably it
helped countries send and receive money
across borders the US also got countries
together with the goal of lowering the
taxes imposed on products flowing in and
out of their country tariffs and through
all these efforts all these new rules
borders opened up investors could put
their money almost anywhere on Earth to
grow new businesses corporations could
look to far away lands for cheaper work
workers to set up their factories the
world became one big market and it
started to benefit hundreds of millions
of
people so much so that even anti-
capitalist China couldn't stay out of
this global economy that was so
unrecognizably open that was so much
more open than anything the world had
ever seen there was way too much money
to be made so China jumped in they said
that they would remain Communists but
they would open up a few dozen of their
coastal cities to be open for business
in this new Global Market
millions of China's rural poor flocked
to the coastal cities these gateways to
the global market they showed up ready
to work and to work for cheap a whir
away over in the United States
corporations looked at all of their
factories in places like Detroit and
buffalo and realized that it would make
a lot more sense for them to move all of
these factories to China where they
could pay workers a fraction of the wage
and spoiler alert all these coastal
cities in China that opened up to the
global economy soon looked like this
hundreds of millions of people in China
lifted out of poverty and thrust into
this new middle and upper class all
thanks to the magic of the global
economy based on the rules and policies
that the US had set up after World War
II it was so good for China and a bunch
of other countries but for the many
Americans whose jobs had just been given
to someone in like Shanghai this didn't
feel like magic it felt like betrayal
like a recipe for poverty and ghost
towns this China shock was one of the
first big tastes of the economic pain
that this global economy could inflict
on huge numbers of people but to
everyone else it was totally worth it
because thanks to this system people
were suddenly seeing prices at their
stores drop further than seemed possible
washing machines shoes tools toasters
couches shirts socks toys mattresses
lawn chairs anything you can think of is
now flowing from Chinese factories and
available for dirt cheap at your local
Walmart all while transforming the lives
of of people in places like Vietnam
India Chile and Thailand who saw huge
economic growth during these years so by
the 80s China's fully in the global
economy and it is a gravy trade the US
and UK both elect leaders who love this
free trade global capitalism more trade
not less is the wave of the future the
new system was boosted by all of this
new technology that was coming up making
it easier to pass information across
borders to move money to move people to
move Goods across the globe a globe that
used to be vast and daunting and closed
but now just looked like a giant
Marketplace all of this transforming in
a matter of
decades but I need to call something out
that is very important and that is maybe
not obvious at this point which is that
the seemingly magical process that made
the world economy do
this wasn't actually thanks to
technology it was thanks to humans most
amazing invention most amazing
technology policy words on a page that
establish rules that countries and
people promise to obey if we all believe
and Obey these rules it creates the
conditions that made the world into a
giant marketplace where a corporation
could Source whatever they needed to
make their product from anywhere in the
world whatever made the most economic
sense soon products as simple as a
t-shirt would travel along an
unfathomably complex supply chain using
material and labor from many countries
all around the globe before eventually
showing up conveniently just in time at
the store policy had created Mass
cooperation between billions of people
who don't speak the same language who
don't know each other but are somehow
all getting in on the same Market this
mental construct of economic policy is
what created globalization the
globalization we know today and what's
crazy to me is that if you Tinker with
the policy if you mess with this you can
reverse a lot of this globalization
which is exactly what's happening right
now there is simply no reason why the
blades for wind turbines can't be built
in Pittsburgh instead of Beijing okay
but let's stick to our timeline here
we're kind of in the '90s and I'll tell
you people in the '90s would have never
guessed what direction this story is
about to go the Soviet Union had just
Fallen free trade and global capitalism
had unambiguously beat communism and the
magic of the free market was seen as the
solution for pretty much everything free
trade had just ended global conflict
between these great superpowers maybe
forever free trade was eradicating
Global poverty free trade was pushing
countries to adopt democracy and here's
Bill Clinton giddy about how good it's
all going predicting that free trade
would bring democracy to China the more
China liberalizes its economy the more
fully it will Liberate the potential of
its people their initiative their
imagination their remarkable Spirit of
Enterprise and when individuals have the
power not just to dream but to realize
their dreams they will demand a greater
say free trade would prevent our age-old
human curse War by so deeply entangling
countries in mutually beneficial deals
that it wouldn't make sense to fight
after all free trade had turned Europe
from a continent ravaged by War to this
tightly knit group where everyone's
holding hands and smiling together why
wouldn't this naturally just happen to
the whole globe China continued to make
stuff and send it to the United States
our dependency on them and them on us
continued to grow and that would surely
prevent any conflict right um
no it it's looking like that's not how
it's going to turn out in fact it's kind
of the opposite the new tariffs from
both sides went into effect earlier this
morning the US has imposed 10% tariffs
on $200 billion worth of Chinese Imports
China is our military's most
consequential strategic competitor and
pacing Challenge in a relatively sudden
shift governments around the world are
undoing a lot of this globalization this
solution to all of our problems they're
rejecting it India is paying companies
to keep their production Within their
own borders especially for important
industries like Pharmaceuticals and
electronics South Korea is giving
taxpayer money to companies to produce
green energy infrastructure instead of
waiting for the free market to come
build it Japan is paying companies to
move production back to Japan and to
move their supply chains away from China
Australia is using taxpayer money to
encourage mining companies to establish
the processing of rare Earth mineral
facilities within their borders instead
of abroad Nigeria is imposing
restrictions on foreign Goods that they
want to see produced domestically like
rice and cement they don't want to be
reliant on other countries and then
you've got Europe where tons of
countries are investing government money
and protecting homegrown industries that
have always been directed by the global
economy like energy Agriculture and cars
the government getting involved in these
markets incentivizes companies and
consumers to make and sell these
products in country as opposed to
looking abroad at the global market and
of course leading out on all of this is
the OG of the modern free market global
economy the United States who is
suddenly changing course from how
they've been operating all the way up
until like Obama like Obama spent a
great deal of his time trying to
increase free trade especially with Asia
then first under Trump and now under
Biden the US is overhauling its economic
policy to turn back some of this free
trade and what's crazy is that both
Republicans and Democrats seem to agree
that we should do this and fast there is
no reason you have this capacity some of
these policies include huge government
spending bills like the chips act which
would allocate over 50 billion
government dollars to companies that
produce microchips here in the United
States instead of in Asia where the free
market had pulled them to set up this is
also happening in other industries that
the government has deemed vital like
critical minerals cars and clean energy
but they're not just giving subsidies
like it's not just government money
washing down on all these industries
it's also barriers Biden is imposing
tariffs on Imports which protects
domestic producers of certain industries
because they no longer have to compete
with the global market they're also
Banning American companies from selling
certain products to China they're
increasing scrutiny on any investment
that comes in from places like China
like this is a big shift and the
question is what happened how did we get
from this free trade Heyday That was
supposed to usher in world peace to this
markets have been whipsawed all morning
and now afternoon by this ongoing trade
in China the short answer is one word
the answer to all of this protection
here's my list of four protections that
best explain this big shift in Economic
Policy first workers which we already
kind of talked about briefly with the
China shock for all the winners of the
global economy there were lots of losers
and a lot of them were communities who
found themselves out of work as their
jobs went to cheaper overseas locations
now listen economists argue as to how
big of a problem this actually was and
you can read all about it in my sources
but the point is that closed factories
and unemployed communities in the Rust
Belt have a major psychological effect
on people who fear that their jobs might
just disappear either abroad or be taken
over by AI so the government is trying
to calm people down by pumping money
into certain sectors to keep jobs in
America the next big realization about
the global economy it doesn't really
care much about how much carbon it pumps
into our atmosphere our world is
barreling towards a very real climate
crisis and governments realize they're
going to have to force the market to get
serious about things like electric cars
solar panels and other green
infrastructure the free market is not
going to incentivize this and if it
doesn't happen we're going to have a
much bigger problem on our
hands one of the best parts of the
global economy is that our products get
made by materials that are being tossed
around the globe at the perfect time at
the perfect place to all come together
to be made into a final product all to
arrive at a shelf at some store so that
we can purchase it these Supply chains
are insane and they cross the entire
planet and it works great until the
world shut down in a global pandemic
leaving people around the world without
the products that they either needed or
just kind of got used to having again
economists argue about how big of a deal
this was a lot of them are like no the
supply chains held up really well during
Co but regardless of what some academic
economists is saying at MIT all of us
are left with a pretty bad taste in our
mouth about Supply chains after Co the
system feels too fragile a lot of us
feel too reliant on a fragile system of
farway Global Connections that could be
rocked at any moment which has led to
these protectionist policies that these
governments hope will bring Supply
chains back inside of their borders okay
finally and perhaps the most important
explanation in all of this is that Bill
Clinton was totally wrong free trade
didn't incentivize China into a
democratic Revolution the world did not
join together in one big free trade
market twoo entangled to fight with each
other in fact quite the opposite has
happened relations between the world's
two largest economies are at their most
tense in years after joining the global
economy China got really rich really
fast they've kind of started to
challenge the us at its own game and now
they have one of the biggest militaries
on the planet and they use that military
to assert their influence around their
region they use their Newfound wealth to
project influence around the world by
building stuff or giving loans to people
and they're kind of trying to Dethrone
the United States as the one who's
calling the shots on the global economic
order I made a whole video about this
that you can go watch if you want but
the big Point here is that the US is
worried about the rapid rise of their
rival across the
ocean especially when the rise of that
rival is in part fueled by American
Technology specifically these little
silicon chips microchips that make
weapons smart and that will be the
brains that power the AI Revolution a
lot of Joe Biden's protectionist
policies are actually just aimed right
at China trying to stop them from using
our own Tech to get ahead of us again I
made an entire video about microchips
you can go into that kind of made a
video about a lot of these things but
yeah Joe Biden is also trying to get the
supply chains for these microchips out
of China's neighborhood meaning out of
Taiwan bringing them back inside our
borders to places like New Albany Ohio
nice and safe in the middle of our
continent so you're going to see a lot
more moments like this with American
Presidents or politicians with hard hats
on speaking at construction sites folks
we need to make the these chips right
here in America to bring down everyday
cost and create good jobs America is
back and America's leading the
way this last point is kind of a brutal
recognition for a lot of people
including me to be honest that our
theory that we would all be more
peaceful if we were more economically
entangled is kind of wrong at least for
now in fact these economic entanglements
are looking like they might turn into
tools of conflict as opposed to prevent
ERS of conflict like China has a near
Monopoly on a lot of The Rare Earth
elements that we need to make a ton of
very important products including
military weapons and if push comes to
shove they could very realistically use
this as leverage and cut us off in the
exact same way that we cut them off
microchips I mean this just happened
Vladimir Putin turned off the pipelines
that pumped natural gas into Europe the
gas that is needed to heat the homes and
run the factories showing us that
economic entanglements can actually be a
weapon and flipping this whole Theory on
its head but yeah Joe Biden is pouring
money into bringing production home and
he has a lot of support from all sides
of the aisle this is like economic
nationalism the government is getting
involved to undo some of what the free
market did in its Heyday which was to
distribute production of stuff where it
made the most economic sense not where
it protected people that means we will
invent It in America and Make It in
America and we're going to make sure we
include all of America so that's where
we're at the world is reacting to some
weaknesses that they see in the global
free trade system they're putting up
barriers in the name of protection and
no one's really sure what that means
like it's kind of hard to not look at
this and draw some parallels with the
1930s when a series of economic crises
LED countries to put up trade barriers
in the name of protection which then led
to ever greater economic Strife leading
to unrest and eventually culminating in
the second world war but don't read too
far into that I'm not trying to like do
one of those things where I'm like every
hundred years history repeats itself
that's not what I think is happening
here but there's some similarities that
we should probably just keep an eye on a
suite of crises that make us turn inward
that surge populism and economic
nationalism and the rise of tensions
between great
Powers hey before you go I need to tell
you one last thing which is that we made
probably our last batch of the poster
that I designed last year it's a poster
called all maps are wrong and I'm very
proud of it it shows all the ways that
you can take our Earth and project it
onto a 2d plane which always comes with
some Distortion anyway it's kind of a
nerdy map lover thing and if you're into
that you should go over and check it out
before they're all gone this is probably
going to be our last batch so get them
while they last and uh the Link's in the
description